All it takes it's this little bit of code to get the amount of time from the
previous frame to the next one. When you call clock.getDelta, it returns a
precise floating point value of the number of seconds that is elapsed since the
clock created or from the last time getDelta was called. By calling this at the
beginning of each render, we can know exactly how much time we should use when
we rotate the drinking bird. This code is how we were rotating the bird, adding
half a degree each frame. If our goal is to rotate 30 degrees per second, we
replace the 0.5 degrees per frame with exactly this. As each frame passes and
the delta gets updated, the object is rotated the proper amount. This works
well while the browser window is visible, but an interesting thing happens if
you start the demo in timed mode, set the frames per second, and then switch to
another browser window, and hide the program. When you come back in a while,
you're likely to see the drinking bird spinning around and around. The problem
is with our function that computes how much to rotate. The assumption in this
code is that the rotation angle will never increase much beyond 103 or negative
22 degrees. However, when this window is hidden, rendering stops. When the
window is exposed again, the renderer gets a huge delta, which the limit
testing code doesn't deal with at all. The bird spins around and around
incredibly fast for a while as the huge value gets damped out. There are a
number of solutions. Here is one that locks the drinking bird directly to the
time itself instead of the change of time, the delta. The method getElapsedTime
gives how many seconds have gone by since the clock option was created. We take
this time and multiply it by 30, the number of degrees per second. We know that
the drinking bird sweeps through a 125 degree arc in both directions for a
cycle of 250 degrees total. By taking the modulus, the remainder after the
division by 250, we get an angle between 0 and 250. If the angle is less than
125 degrees, we rotate the bird forwards. Otherwise, we rotate it backwards,
adjusting for the starting and ending angles of negative 22 and 103 degrees.
Now if the browser window is exposed later, the time is always going to resolve
to a proper angle. The moral is, when you design any animation driven by time,
make sure it's bulletproof from large time changes between renders. By the way,
there's one more mode in the demo called wave. It's my attempt to make the bird
swing back from the glass at a varying rate, instead of moving back at a
constant number of degrees per second. This avoids a bit of the jerk that
occurs when the direction is reversed. One nice thing about using the time as
an input is that you can then decide what the angle should be at various times.
I can't say my attempt is all that convincing, but at least it's a bit nicer.